Catelyn Stark: In the snow-capped Mountains
of the Moon, standing high above the rich
lands of the Vale, stands the Eyrie, a storied
and impregnable fortress said to have built
by the legendary Mountain Kings in the Age
of Heroes.
It is the stronghold of House Arryn, one of
the oldest noble families in Westeros.
Their sigil, a soaring white falcon over a
crescent moon; their words, "As High As Honor."
The Arryns are direct descendants of Andal
invaders, who sailed across the Narrow Sea
and came ashore at the Fingers.
According to legend, Ser Artys Arryn, known
as "the Winged Knight," soared through the
skies atop a giant falcon, landing on the
peak of the highest mountain, where he defeated
the Griffin King in battle.
It was the Andals' first great victory over
the First Men.
And SerArtys was duly rewarded.
He was declared King of the Mountain and the
Vale, and the region renamed "the Vale of
Arryn."
Thousands of years later, Aegon the Conqueror
arrived in Westeros.
House Arryn bent the knee to Aegon and his
dragons and were allowed to maintain their
control of the region as Lords Paramount of
the Vale and Wardens of the East.
Petyr Baelish: The Vale of Arryn was the last
of the great kingdoms left.
Old and proud, House Arryn did what they always
did in times of strife: they shut the Bloody
Gate, sealing off the Vale.
Then, the Queen Regent Sharra of House Arryn
retreated with her son, the boy-king Ronnel,
into the Eyrie, their family's impregnable
fortress.
From the top of their mountain, they could
look down on Westeros far below, its problems
hidden beneath the clouds.
But one day, Queen Sharra entered the outer
courtyard to find her young son sitting on
the knee of Visenya Targaryen and ogling her
dragon, Vhagar, beside her.
Just as he asked for another cake at dinner,
little King Ronnel asked his mother if he
could ride on the nice lady's dragon.
Visenya smiled at Sharra.
So, Sharra imagined, did Vhagar.
Remembering her manners, Sharra asked if she
could have Visenya brought some wine or food,
she must be tired after such a long flight.
But Visenya demurred.
Bored with his mother's pleasantries, Ronnel
demanded an answer.
Poor boy.
He didn't even understand the question.
Sharra hesitated for a moment, then asked
Visenya, as a mother, if it was safe for the
boy.
Visenya assured her it was.
What choice did Sharra have?
Whilst her son circled the castle, she collected
his little ringlet, her own regent's coronet,
and the ancient Falcon Crown of Mountain and
Vale, which the Arryns had worn for thousands
of years.
Ronnel had taken to the sky as a king, but
he landed as a lordling.
Perhaps he considered his ancient rights a
fair trade for a few minutes of flight, as
a little boy would.
More likely, he didn't even notice the three
crowns at Visenya's feet or recognize the
swords of his garrison beside them.
Catelyn Stark: Over the centuries, the House
Arryn remained loyal to the Targaryen dynasty.
Until Lord Jon Arryn joined with Houses Baratheon
and Stark in rebellion against Mad King Aerys.
Petyr Baelish: No army in the Seven Kingdoms
can match the pride and chivalry of the Knights
of the Vale.
After all, they were the first true knights
in Westeros.
The Knights of the Vale were originally the
knights of Andalos, an eastern nation whose
people invaded Westeros thousands of years
ago.
From the sea, the Vale seemed to the Andals
an ideal new home.
A wide, fertile valley isolated from the rest
of Westeros and its kingdoms by a great mountain
range.
The First Men who held it, moreover, were
sparse and divided and waded into battle with
bronze axes and armor that couldn't match
Andal horses and steel.
But what the First Men lacked in weaponry
they made up for in ferocity.
Finally uniting behind King Robar Royce, the
First Men smashed the Andals in battle after
battle, reclaiming the Vale and pushing the
invaders back to the sea from whence they'd
come.
Learning from the First Men, the remaining
Andals united behind a leader of their own.
Not a king or a lord, but a knight who'd been
born in the Vale and knew it as well as the
First Men.
Ser Artys Arryn, known as the Falcon Knight.
The armies of the First Men and the Andals
met beneath the Giant's Lance to decide the
fate of the Vale.
SerArtys had many more mounted knights than
the First Men, who preferred to fight on foot.
But the First Men had seized the high ground,
digging trenches in front of their ranks and
lining them with sharpened stakes smeared
with offal and excrement.
Six times the Andal knights charged, and six
times the First Men threw them back.
But on the seventh, a fearsome Andal warrior
broke through the ranks of the First Men,
and the Andals rushed through the gap.
If King Robar had been wiser, he would have
retreated and saved his army for another day.
Then again, if he'd been wise at all, he'd
never have risked his army of foot soldiers
against mounted knights in the first place.
When King Robar saw the falcon helm of SerArtys
across the field, he wagered that the Andals
would break if they lost their leader and
rode hard for the Falcon Knight.
The singers paint a pretty picture of the
battle—the king in flashing bronze armor,
the knight in silvered steel.
But the duel lasted no longer than a verse
of the songs.
For King Robar had taken a Valyrian sword
off a dead Andal lord, and it sheared through
SerArtys' helm much like a bird's wing through
the air.
As the Falcon Knight tumbled to Earth, King
Robar thought he'd won his desperate gamble.
Then he heard the trumpets behind him.
When he turned, he saw 500 fresh Andal knights
pouring down the Giant's Lance, and the man
at its head was also the man at Robar's feet.
For SerArtys, unique in that age, or indeed
any age, esteemed cunning even more than martial
strength and had clad one of his knights in
his spare suit of armor, leaving him to die
at Robar's hand while SerArtys took his best
horsemen up a goat track he knew from childhood.
The charge of the Andal knights broke the
last great army of the First Men, who would
never again threaten the new Knights of the
Vale.
Some of the defeated would even join their
ranks in the years to come, but many more
fled to the mountains, choosing savagery over
submission.
Ever since, the Knights of the Vale enjoyed
an exclusive position in Westeros.
They could sally forth from the Vale at will,
knowing that if battle went against them,
they could retreat through the Bloody Gate
where no army could follow.
Until the dragons changed the game.
When Aegon the Conqueror landed in Westeros,
the Queen Regent of the Vale shut the Bloody
Gate against the Targaryens and massed the
Knights of the Vale behind it to lock it.
But Visenya simply flew her dragon to a balcony
of the Eyrie, where the boy king was playing
and gave the boy a ride around the castle
in return for his mother's submission.
With the Conquest, no more could the Knights
of the Vale hide behind their mountains, nor,
they soon discovered, did they need to.
For thousands of years, the other kingdoms
had warred and treated to balance each other's
might.
whilst the Vale kept to itself.
None realized what power the Vale could have
until Jon Arryn defied the Iron Throne, refusing
to surrender Ned Stark and Robert Baratheon
to the Mad King.
The North, the Riverlands, and the Stormlands
couldn't have beaten the other three kingdoms
be themselves.
But the Knights of the Vale rode with them.
After all, the Vale's isolation does breed
an abundance of honor and pious bleating,
which governs their decisions instead of foresight.
Like a blind man who can only guess where
his horse is taking him, I doubt Jon Arryn
had even prepared for civil war when he raised
his banners instead of handing over his young
wards, Ned Stark and Robert Baratheon, to
the Mad King.
Honor demanded, and Lord Arryn obeyed.
He'd have done the same if the boys hadn't
been the lords of two Great Houses, who could
field mighty armies of their own.
But perhaps I give him too little credit.
After all, if the war went against them, only
Lord Arryn had a nice impregnable castle to
retreat into; and he was wise enough to take
poor Lysa Tully into his bed to win the Riverlands
as allies.
Jon Arryn won, then Jon Arryn died.
Impregnable.
That's how the Vale sees itself.
Shielded from Westeros by its mountains.
They call the entrance to their lands the
Bloody Gate because, during the Age of Heroes,
a dozen armies supposedly smashed themselves
against it.
Except the Vale has been conquered.
Those vaunted mountains didn't stop the Andals
who came by the eastern sea.
The people of the Vale say that Ser Artys
Arryn, the Andal general, flew on the back
of a giant falcon and slew the Griffin King
on top of the tallest mountain.
During Aegon's conquest, one of his sisters
did the same, flying a dragon over the Bloody
Gate and up to the Eyrie, the Arryn stronghold.
And the Arryn boy king yielded the Vale in
return for a ride on the beast.